okay will for people who are joining our
livestream
this is a design meeting about future
features in Wolfram language so let's
get going yeah so let's see is this so
this is the discussion of column map and
and new ways of accessing part to
extract parts from expression and so
this is a bit long I will try to defend
some some proposal and the main idea I
can't summarize is that in the same way
that you have some symbolic names like
all and spine for lists of indices in
part we need something similar for lists
of of positions in extract and what we
have here is some sort of way of
understanding this proportion talk about
web wizard what does this have to do
with column map
yes so the idea is running like having
functions column map we could have
something like called like map odd and
then in the last argument we have a
language for collections of positions
including columns rows and
generalizations of that I still think we
need a function called column map so we
discussed that you have another book
called column functions or one so
perhaps we should like look at that
compare okay yes so so so far
way we have been doing this is for
example like you have their map add a
function or comma 2 etc we have to refer
to all elements in the second column so
this idea is how to generalize that to
something more flexible and follows
better our language for the
specification for position specification
okay but still it still makes sense to
have column map even if we have a way to
specify something that says for example
you know map over columns 2 & 3
yes right I mean but map over columns
two and three here will be all comma
list two three correct
oh come at least two three yes that's
our current notation for that no go
ahead maybe we should get whatever the
proposal is here what is the yes so the
proposal is first in order to have to
understand it so I wanted to make the
point that when we talk in the foreign
language about lists in part specs and
position specs we have three levels of
lists what I call just some random names
spine list position list on multi list
and and spine list is what we use import
so when we say part of a matrix 2 comma
3 that's like a spine 2 comma 3 no it's
a multi it's your multi thing I would
think spine in the sense that we could
imitate it with spine 2 comma 3 and 2 3
4 could be spine to for okay fine but if
you said to 4 that would not be that
would be the multi notice plan - 4 e yes
I still want to call it span list multi
list is going to be a multiple list of
positions which is what position returns
ok so yeah ok ok so they the points so
yeah so we now start understand part in
the sense that it has a span list of
indices
then position which has always a double
list the out of list is a multi-position
equivalent and the inner list is a
position okay okay so if we want to if
we go to some other function like
indexed which is further down okay then
it has a list also and that list is a
position always a position even if it is
an empty position
okay okay and then this is in
preparation to extract which is the
complicated thing so extract can have a
zero one two or three levels of lists
and okay and when we are talking about
three levels of lists I think the only
possible way to understand this is
understanding the meaning of these three
levels of lists so the the outermost one
is is the word
multi then the second the next one the
middle one is the position list and the
inner one is this panelist the one that
goes into part so my little equation did
we place this design before span existed
I mean extract can also use span counted
if we well it should I'm not sure it
does but it should it will put it in two
levels of lists why does it work in one
level and zero levels of Lists because
then they precisely the type of list
doesn't match so for example you cannot
say all extract ABC all right because
span represents a list of what I call as
panelists but if we put a listing only
one listing extract it is a position
list now that
that should work okay so that may be a
bug but that doesn't work because if you
replace it by what it is want middle
east one two three then it does work
okay so that the main point here is that
when we want to refer in extract on
other fat or other functions like every
place part flatten out etc to to to a
collection of positions we should have
also some sort of symbolic way of
referring to them and we have one
present for that which is banned yes so
band is is a collection of positions
it's a geminal or something parallel to
other ever yes right so when I think of
columns or rows or a marginalized object
called slice
I think this corresponds to a collection
of positions and that's something that
will be nice to have to slice an array
on a data set in arbitrary ways okay
so you're proposing a function called
slice for example yeah and what would it
do I have a in this section confirming
one I have a termination
okay when I saw problem one it just
didn't seem like that was it yes so so
sliced so the idea is we need we need a
way of saying I won the third row at the
level one the third element at level one
and then at level two I want the second
and third and at level right so then
further down would pass this to columns
and rows but
is working on on say matrix I define
matrix somewhere else
yes the very beginning I guess yeah okay
so I'm trying to understand what this is
yes so this would say at level 1 extra
make make the make the index always -
exactly so yes that that's the second
rule okay then we can say we have that
array at level yeah that's the same
thing okay level 3 make it always a 3 ok
I get it yes yes or we can select two of
them so this is the sort of thing that
we would do partially in extract with
lots of always combined with with
numbers and why isn't that's just a
function slice exterior to extract wise
wise sliced part of extract I mean could
and and can slice also occur and other
functions like part well remember that a
slice is the symbolic form of
multi-position so because part cannot
take a multi-position part cannot take
slice but we can make slice to be an
operator form that does basically what
it does instruct but the main point is
that now we can put slice in my barding
insert and be heat we could put it in
replace part etc i 3 we could put it in
a sparse array because it's like band it
represents a collection of objects or of
positions which i think it is
main thing we are missing when we have
yeah yeah yes when we have a position
spec we always have to be very explicit
and list on the list of positions well
so the difference here I mean the
alternative to slice 3 arrow 3 would be
part blank comma blank comma 3 so right
part hmm slice the arrow 3 it's just at
the third level the part specification I
mean it could almost be extract of array
comma blank blank 3 yes with the way I
mean I don't know this would work does
this work all all three when we have all
it does when we have so so the current
prescription we have is we need to have
polls at the beginning but for example
if you have cereals then this doesn't
work so it works with four columns but
not four rows
it is been so wait a minute you're
saying if you want the first but but I
understand what way if we're taking it
for the row
why isn't just extract comma 2 and that
will get the root oh no what does that
do differently well try to put it in a
in a in a list well this one gives that
same as this is right mm-hmm
yes so now you say extract array comma
slice 1 arrow to it's going to give that
same thing no no it it flattens it
well the array the array is is
[Music]
now I think well this is doing is it's
saying get me all parts hmm I mean it's
something more like this isn't it I mean
it's it's more like saying
you know to blank-blank there's more
like a list with her yes yes because the
extract takes a list of positions it has
to be as a flattened list of positions
right and that would be an example there
of that position so that's an
alternative to saying slice one a to
arrow a one arrow - I mean interestingly
this particular thing is like a sparse
array that is of the form one arrow -
with the fourth element blank
the way to do it oh I'm sorry I need to
say three not like mm-hmm
there we go so that thing there is that
okay all right so you're proposing here
so now it's when we can define a
particular case of row and column which
are just the cases at level one and two
we call it row slice by the way let me
just um it's a little obscure so what
this would look like is you would say I
mean would you be able to say then
matrix
heart row slice column slice extract who
could say extract matrix come on
counselor I don't think that's good
enough because I think we need a way of
getting
I mean this thing here this column part
type functionality we don't want to have
to be doing extracts to get that
mm-hmm well somehow because
these are so many functions I wanted to
to see whether there is some idea that
allows us to have the same functionality
through their current functions no I
understand but I can't be too
complicated otherwise it's gonna defeat
itself what is your problem - here yes
so here we are discussing two different
things one is how to map a function over
all the elements of a column versus how
to map a function over the column itself
yes what you do to that
well isn't that apply ad which we don't
have well the problem is if we can
collapse if we have a matrix we can
collapse a row to a number and still
preserve a list of rows except for one
which is number but if we have a matrix
and we want to collapse a column to a
number I don't know what the result is
we cannot represent it with with an
array
wait a minute so so but you can
represent it with a ragged array right
so if you if one column has been turned
into a number no it would we can do that
with a rugged erase for a row but for a
column we can't because somehow we have
right
I have holes yes okay yes so we could do
some sort we could have some sort of
structure of array in which internally
we totally transposed for but it looks a
bit too complicated okay the sort of
thing yes I agree that there's an issue
here which would be to get to depth n in
the data set yeah I remember now this
time what that query is but let's not
worry about that this well normal data
set is just a way of rearranging the
data set so we can forget about normal
dataset
okay okay so the point there is to be
able to again say do this operation at
this level yes I mean why aren't you
just able to do a map a map actually
specifying the level spec at which you
want to do the operation but I guess
it's just
certainly the query notation yeah but
okay but but go ahead yes it is to find
a generalization of column operations
which also works for deeper yes that was
the question right I agree
that's the question however I think
column is a common enough concept that
we should support that on its own even
if there is a more general formalism
that allows us to go deeper okay so the
point that you're making is that the
deeper concept is something of the form
slice of level spec arrow match of the
indices right yes
it's basically a sparse array
representation of the index of the index
list yes in the same way that we have
bands which is kind of diagonal based
this is some sort of plain hyperplane
based in the in the multi dimension
multi mention of special finishes
right but what if I wanted to combine
band with this what you mean generating
band well in other words what this is
doing is rectilinear Li it's saying that
index number three is always equal to
blah right right whereas band is saying
for example the pair of indices at
levels three and four are always equal
to like for example we're getting a band
where the pair of indices three and four
o is equal yep mm-hmm
so I mean in a sense a generalization
here would be some something like um
your slice well it's not really quite
right I mean I'm saying it almost would
be slice to for arrow X blank explain
would represent a generalized band
relative to levels two and four just ban
generalized it's levels it can handle
deeper cases but I think it's always
diagonal based I mean you cannot
make it more tilted or less tilted until
our entrepreneur is this doing that but
this is saying that this is tuned on
this is saying ignore indices 1 & 3 but
making indices 2 & 4 always agree
I mean you know this is
world of tenses I mean that's a repeated
index and what does that really mean
that means
material for the trace for the you know
summation convention or something the
raw material for doing the Einstein
summation convention but it is it's just
coming out as a list rather than coming
out as the result am I right yes the
tensor contract will use also pairs
indicating which levels are the same
and why is this different from
contract I see the contraction
it performs an operation which is the
plus operation yes
arguably if we had a tensor you know
arguably we can have things which are a
family of functions about tensors around
surprise we haven't run into the case of
[Music]
you know we want elements of an array
that match a particular pattern do we
have a way to do that
not that I know I don't remove any
function that uses pattern matching on
indices its life a lot replaced part
does Ison but part for example I think
we've discussed having part deal with
pattern specifications but we've never
done it I think it would be more
difficult to do it in impart aspects but
in position specs if replaced part can
do it then extract can do it as well and
all the others like insert and delete
right well let's take a look does a guy
similar extract is not doing this right
now
it's stuck is doesn't I think that's
worth looking at okay but so we've got
two things here one is you know could we
have
um let's return just the fishes column
right um that's good question does it
return does column apply just return
that column or does it return the thing
reduced by that column I think it
returns just that column I was thinking
about that that seems too destructive to
me I have a comment there and adds its
have a comment on our live stream from
Michael Hale saying the case he wanted
for column map was not the element-wise
was not element wise like map at
but that will be some use of Colin
replaced his saying
I don't Ali understand that but go ahead
maybe maybe he means that it is taking a
function f and mapping that function
across every column
well certainly Coulomb map is more
complicated and calm extract because
golem extract either if it is extracting
a column or the list of elements of a
column it's the same result but with map
mapping on the elements or mapping on
the column the whole column is very
different so we would need a way of a
specifying which one we want
wait a minute spell mapping yeah right
the whole column or a mapping across the
elements of the column I mean isn't that
the difference to map and apply
I would respect map on the column to
take the list and not to replace the
head list no I agree with you I agree
with you so that's what I'm saying
column apply would replace the head
yeah yes but then then it will be total
it will be plus column of like plus I
see I see I see I see I see I see fine
um okay so what's this comment from
Michael Hale here turning map at the
column map doesn't save as much as
turning this
you
you
okay who understands this oh this is a
mutable operation with an all on the
left-hand side which I don't think we've
seen I'm not a big fan of these things
with of doing assignment type stuff but
maybe it's worth I think that's an
orthogonal question to the one that
we're pursuing here yes I think this is
the L value version of what we want to
do right so once we have done the
operation agree we assign well we assign
to potentially a slice
all right let's unravel here what we're
talking about
okay so first question is is there a way
is it okay first question is supporting
patterns and things like extract let's
explore that possibility
second thing is supporting essentially a
sparse index syntax like slice which may
also be useful yeah yeah I see it like
the horizontal version of that fair
enough okay so then the third thing is
[Music]
you know the column functions the column
star functions of which several are
obviously useful you know so call of
apply I'll change that to say plus um I
mean
I'm not sure that's the only thing
that's worth having I mean I think is it
useful no it's not useful in other words
that there's the question is does the
thing return just that column
or is it the case that to achieve the
thing I want I will be saying total of
column extract of array
you
you know I could do that yeah exactly
is the proper way of
of forgetting only the total of that
column I play I don't see what it could
return that okay not totally uncommon
thing would be to take a data set I mean
actually that's kind of an abuse of our
dataset mechanism and to add a row that
contains totals for example but for
example column apply on a data set we
could invent some mechanism that somehow
remembers that there is a hole in a list
it
it's like having missing in the middle
missing part in the middle of a list but
it was her race and something we can do
it Oh Michael hell is pointing out that
tongue we can already do the thing that
he gave before and that he was hoping
that column
[Music]
that column map
would allow him to rescale for example
all the data in the B column I see the
problem is rescale is that it takes the
whole column and returns a list in other
words there's there's gluing back a list
there's applying an operation okay so
let's think about how this works with
rows is there a way to apply an
operation to a whole row and put that
row back into the you know assume you
have an operation that map's lists of
length n to lists of length then mm-hmm
how do you replace the list of length
then hat that corresponds to column well
let's to start off with row 7 with that
list of length then think of normalized
for example I think we can we can just
map a normalized my bad tune or my sad I
didn't grow number I see what you say I
switch to say so whatever however the
for so long as it does that mapping so
long as it returns the thing of the
right length we can just do that as a
map on to the index that was above the
thing we're looking at right so I guess
the question is what's the equivalent
for a column right
so how do we
the column so to speak some of that the
whole column is replaced
and you know the rather ugly column
replaced s' of a column extract is
really not very good okay walking
through what does column map to again so
good
yes so column map has two possible
things to do and and and let's say their
origin of our discussion so it either
does the map at all comma two or or it
does transpose map at first level and
then transpose again what's the
difference trainers yes perhaps we can
do an example construct a matrix simple
matrix 1 2 3 4 2 by 2 matrix ok ok so we
can have map at F Matt automata and then
we can have map normalize of transpose
of Matt sorry my bad my pet of normalize
why am i doing normalize don't be able
see what it did because then otherwise
we cannot say
and it's common is to just transpose of
Matt and then - but transpose Matt and
then commit and then transpose again the
whole thing so the point is
that F was marked locally at each
element while normalized act was able to
act on the whole column at the same time
yeah I understand and then glue it back
in again
exactly yeah Michael Hill is pointing
out use transpose for arrays but not
associations anyway so the operation
that we need here is one that does a
whole column takes a function applies it
to the whole column and by apply mean
wraps around the whole column mm-hmm
assumes that F returns something which
is fits back into that column and then
puts it back in there right yes but the
reason that we need such a special type
of function that has that property yeah
otherwise yeah otherwise we'll end up
with a ragged array with something not
transportable back to change normalized
to F I understand I understand I
understand but I'm saying that that yeah
well if we
differently it would just be a ragged
array wouldn't it no it wouldn't be it
you're saying it can't even be
represented because a column with a
knife wraps around it where does it go
it's a scalar value where does it go
exactly humph
okay so the important point here is that
we actually have two operations one is a
kind of column it's almost like a column
construct in our modern version of
construct hmm yeah well I think that's
utterly obscure I think the first this
is what I called problem one in front -
the first one can be solved with some
language for columns so some person of
what we now do with all gamma - all
whole etc the slice the slice game yup
and and and rows and columns particular
ization
yeah the second one is the difficult one
which is the one we're now talking about
exactly because it's very specific to a
certain type of function
unless we invent a notation for the
transposition of this thing that that
can become a transpose well I don't
understand it seems to me it's perfectly
okay to say you give a function if that
function doesn't have the property that
it returns a list of the same length
then you get an error mm-hmm but it
still has to be the case that in general
you could take a sub matrix I mean get
in general this is a um you know this is
more like some kind of you know sub
array map mm-hmm or array map for
example so a possibility would be
essentially sub array mapping so array
map would take a function f and an array
and position specs
it would essentially glue back in so I'm
wondering how this relates to block Matt
for example what other things related to
block map here
okay so this is an hour log of block map
except that in the case of block map
yeah it's a little different but but I
mean I'm so here it's saying F has to be
essentially a list of all function or
not quite really list of all if F was
listable then it guarantees to have this
property right exactly
well that won't be the most exciting
function if it if it is list of all
right because then it goes back to forum
one yes but I think the subarray mapping
um right so what you're saying here is
that if I were to say array map F array
all come a to what would that do
we'll take column to apply F to column
two and assume that it returns a list of
the same length it will glue that back
in making sense somehow all comma 2
represents the list of individual
objects not there not the column itself
well that's true in the other mapping
functions it might not be true in a
right map how would you represent that
sub array I mean it's like a region of
interest mask but we're doing in a
different way because that's that's like
with bounding boxes and things yes I
think this is where this notation of
level 2 goes to 2 sounds like more
targeted towards the column is the slice
notation yeah okay so I mean the
alternative then a slice to arrow to
here or something yeah but this
operation okay so column apply really
doesn't make sense here
so this probably probably should
well be you know this shouldn't do yeah
that's probably not correct okay um all
right let's keep going in our agenda I
think we're gonna have to come back to
this but it seems to me that I mean
there are some functions here like
column extract column map to
fairly uncontroversial there are very
profound but they seem fairly
uncontroversial in yes as as versions of
mapping over certain over over all
elements of certain slices yes that's
correct
so this one however would be I mean the
general case is to take a sub array and
glue the sub array apply an operation to
it even a sub array that isn't
necessarily you know reaching all the
way across the array you know some
random sub matrix okay so the question
is whether that is column or a column
apply or whether we just don't have
column up like is too confusing
though it's well the column apply of
total comma X no that's not right either
all right I mean normalize would be an
example of what you could do with column
apply yeah as I said data said we may
have a bit more flexibility if we can
start some internal representation of
something with holes but with a raise I
don't see the reason oh yeah I get it I
get it I good um okay I mean that
doesn't look obviously stupid to me
that's column apply normalize it's a
little weird to use the word apply hmm
and I don't like using operate or
something I think this is a mapping
function it's it's mapping this function
and it's not destroying any head just
rubbing I don't I hate that one
you know that's otherwise known as array
map exactly exactly so that's what I'm
saying that it should have the map Hindu
name yeah but what's the column to
distinguish it from column map which is
go to that column and map I mean really
it's two different levels right go one
of them is its mapping element wise in
the column and the other is okay so this
is really yeah the issue is here element
eyes thus the subarray mapping right so
column map we are imagining is an
element-wise mapping yeah whereas what
we want here I mean it is just like our
construct function isn't it
perhaps it's the difference between
column map and column about something
that possible
is that plausible let's see why would
that be plausible so map at we just use
the column as the at to where to do the
mapping I'm not sure doesn't seem
obviously crazy or perhaps it's like my
poll I don't think so
map all is something yet different right
right I don't think that's right
we had a comment here from sander on our
livestream I'll just paste it in um
how to take the last X elements of a
list even if the length of the list is
less than X earth does that mean
let's see but what do you mean by the
last X elements up to 5
is this the it is maybe their discussion
of the opportunities no yes yes yes yes
under down to business which we never
actually added all right I think that's
not relevant to this discussion can put
that on the list but um yeah okay saying
say you want the last five elements but
the list is only four elements long yes
we're aware of this I mean this is kind
of the down - question yes which is an
interesting one which we could perhaps
put on another agenda but okay but we're
going to run out of time here but but so
summarizing this I agree with you I mean
maybe we should go ahead and implement
some of these like column map column map
at these other column functions okay
probably not column apply um did we ever
get this one the array real able
function which has had multiple names
yeah that should be on the list okay so
we've got some column functions we've
also got this notion of an array map and
slice is yet a different thing or we've
also got the patterns for extract so
self
things to think through and potentially
implement I think yeah let's take a look
at database dataset map what is this yes
so this was a suggestion of returning a
data set for a map operation in because
we remember the original objects well I
say that's kind of interesting to me
this is a bit like in the same way that
we have the difference between gather by
and group of pi just similar operation
but you know remembering so this would
be the data set version of I mean that
could be an association version of the
still well we already have an
association map to do that so this is
basically just wrapping data set around
it so in my opinion that that's enough I
see I see that's just this exactly I
think the only thing order is getting
for this is some kind of printer you
know print form someone is commenting on
why add column map given that we already
have map at an extract the reason is and
it's a change over the last 30 years in
what I believe about language design
which is if there's a thing a function
that you can readily name or you can
bundle functionality into that thing
under that name it makes sense to do it
rather than to have it be an idiom based
on primitives because it gives you more
when you read code it gives you more
information about what the person was
trying to do to see column map rather
than an extract of a you know map at an
extract and so on for what it's worth
okay so I don't think data set map is
gonna make it for right now okay all
through an any through out of these like
through
is to Matt oh my gosh so any through is
to true what is this - this is applying
a bunch of prey
kids say to a given value and checking
whether any of them returns true also
any through list prime Q integer Q even
Q comma 3 with a list with a list of
functions this is crazy
yeah I think again that we have a simple
enough yeah I just don't think this is
worth it okay um okay
what else do we have to look at today I
don't think we have enough time to
really start going into um yeah we've
got a
stuff about clean data set and so on I
don't think we've also got this array
association thing is that do we need to
go through that some more or not I think
so I think we should implement something
and then discuss a proposal with and
implementation is okay with us is this
group involved I suspect this group is
not involved with the chat functionality
language design no not okay question for
Xavier if he's here um is okay how is
the data set up date going so still
focusing on the bugs for the moment
mostly the formatting bugs now terms of
the type system we have almost fixed all
works so yeah the first part now I just
focus on the formatting before adding
new functionalities
okay so listen one thing that we really
need to do take care of is this business
about whether the data set is stored in
the notebook or not that's a big mess
right now have you been dealing with
that yes so I've tried and there are
three some works there is some issue is
the dynamic process of that I said so
yeah it's it's a bit complicated but
yeah there is a important work to fix
before that to be able to store okay but
you you're on top of that and and the
mechanism you're gonna use is similar to
the way that the automatic storage works
for things like audio is that right this
is not clear yet mainly because it
doesn't seem to be adapt it I mean if
you have a know do you have some
particular formatting you have something
that you'd like you can click on so it's
not clear how you can do that for the
desert where we want to put this well
okay but I mean what happens with audio
right is that we will say something like
audio let's say audio capture of
hello why it's taking so long
and now I'm totally confused by what
this is doing maybe this one wasn't long
enough for this to happen but normally
it would have a thing that says store in
the file or not right
yes what it goes about some special yeah
okay so we have to record longer but but
and then if you don't say store in the
file then you kind of know when you get
it back what is the UX when you get it
back if you didn't store it in the file
all right so I think that's the kind of
thing we want for data set is that it
should default I don't know what happens
in like wolfram script if you don't have
a UI here um yeah I don't know you
should check data set him off from
script make sure that doesn't do
something crazy
but in addition and I have no idea
what's the output form of the data set
do you know I would put form as opposed
to standard form formatting yes you
should check that that's been got right
yeah I think you just plain data set I
mean is it okay but it hopefully it
doesn't have all of the type crud in it
no okay fine
that will be fine if that's what's been
done but then this question about
whether it's storm you should check but
this question of whether it's stored in
the file I do think that you know kind
of status line underneath is a
reasonable way to handle that yeah okay
and what about the options to dataset
for formatting specifications so yeah
this was a discussion with Tenley and
yeah yes thanks and Lou and so we have
ratified a lot of option that we can add
so with the name and what they will do
so so basically it remains only the
implementation now but first this
to solve all the formatting books okay
all right um okay fine all right
hopefully you will make good progress on
that all right I think we should wrap
but what happened to flattened by the
way another one I was tracking here um I
was discussing when he discuss it with
you dang he had concerns about about it
he always has concerns didn't he isn't
here today
right no no okay
let's hope we can make something work
there you know it I think it's a useful
piece of functionality um let's try to
address whatever concerns that I have
but if it's some concern about how if
things are encrusted with holds and so
on something isn't going to work I don't
think that's the issue here I mean they
don't remember right now but yeah let's
discuss using to make sure okay
okay sounds good all right oh that's
interesting Michael Hale is saying is
having a new biology day to post on
Washington community that's there
tomorrow
okay look forward to it um all right
thanks a lot guys and bye to everybody
on the livestream it's SIA